[Music]
about stochastic variance reduction
methods right thank you so I would like
to thank the organizers to invite to
invite me to come to some Institute to
talk about some recent work we did last
summer so this is a some work so Simon
do from CMU with Deb for his summer
intern last summer and I have a
background work in reinforcement
learning this is a ballot these are
talked about reinforcement learning but
this is not a trade a typical thing that
you that seems a you finds common in be
impossible learning work because it has
used some of the some of the recent
advances in optimization to solve
reinforcement learning problems and I'm
still learning this kind of topic and I
think that some of the ideas can be very
powerful and I hope that you'll find it
interesting too so reinforcement
learning so just very briefly so it's
about finding a policy to maximize
long-term reward in particular we have a
agent or robot here taking actions to
affect the world and in return we live
see reward so one step immediate reward
from the world and the next states and
this and then this interaction repeats
and over time we want to we want to look
at this quantity called the expected
long-term return from a certain state we
call it value of a state this is a
discounted total discount accumulated
reward for the future by following that
policy to choose actions an end goal or
VAR l roughly speaking is to optimize a
policy so that this V function is
maximized so this tablet's is sometimes
called policy optimization in this talk
however I'm going to talk about a
special
most special case of reinforcement
learning a specialized case where we are
given a fixed policy and then we just
want to estimate or evaluate that policy
without optimizing it so although it
seems simpler it turns out to be a
crucial step in some of the policy
improvement algorithms like policy
iteration or actor critique and it can
be interesting of it on its own for
example since some people have talked
about machine teaching today you can
think of the states as to measure the
the state of the some learning state of
a student and then this long estimating
the value function is the same as
estimating or predicting the long-term
how long-term success of this teaching
strategy PI on a particular student in a
current state and because of that the
convenience let's drop the dependence on
PI and a for the rest of the talk
because now they're fixed so all again
all we need to do is to estimate the
value of the state and in here in this
talk we focus on linear function
approximation which I'll describe more
precisely later and then we look at the
batch setting where we assume that data
are given beforehand so this is not a
online learning setting where we see a
stream of data coming in we only we're
only given a set a fixed set of data and
we try to compute or estimate the value
function based on this data set in this
setting so here are the main results so
what we what we have done here is to
propose first all the algorithms that
gradient like algorithms that enjoys
linear convergence what it means is that
in order for the algorithm to compute
and solution that is within optimal
epsilon test within epsilon distance to
the true parameter that we care about we
only need nd Times log 1 over Epsilon
many steps all
no complicity to to do it and n is
number of theta and D is the the number
of features or dimension of the data so
this is in contrast to previous work
where you either use a batch algorithm
to compute exact solution that normally
scales quadratically with the dimension
or if you use gradient descent like
algorithm to solve it and then the
convergence is slower in terms of one
over epsilon dependence so if you look
at this so we either gain a factor of D
compared to this one or we have an
exponential speed-up if you look at the
dependence on one of epsilon this work
the key technical ingredients are these
the first thing I think is perhaps the
most interesting to me is that for
policy evaluation in reinforcement
learning as you see soon it's usually
described as a fixed point solution of
some bellman equation but here we took a
different approach by reformulating this
solution or this equation as a set of
point optimization problem it seems to
make the problem more complicated but it
turns out that once we do this then
something nice happens and we're able to
apply some of the advanced optimization
techniques such as stochastic variance
we do variance reduction techniques to
to speed up the optimization and then
most of the analysis goes to analyzing
eigenvalues of the corresponding matrix
and the update rules but these the third
step is most technical I think that the
first one would be is very interesting
to do this one list and all the results
including the algorithms and the
analysis can be extended not directly to
more complicated situations where you
have eligibility traces or policy
learning which I'll explain a little bit
more during the talk so if you need to
remember one slide this is the domain
without
and for the talk I'm going to have
described some of the details so let's
start with problem the problem set up
just to give you an idea of the notation
and what kind of objective function we
try to optimize so here in this case we
we model the problem as a Markov reward
process this is different from typical
reinforcement learning where we often
look at Markov decision process here we
look at a post evaluation right so
there's no action so we remove the
action and MPP becomes MRP just the
reward you can think of it as there is a
Markov chain
with a reward function with with ward
observation and that's before the value
function is just the the total sum of
this counter rewards for the future okay
if you start from that state you can and
one Foundation will result in in
reinforcement learning is the bellman
equation which is a quick which gives a
recursive relation of state variants
used here so what it says is that if you
look at the long-term reward if you look
at the long-term reward of a certain
state in the same as the once every word
plus the features or the future the
long-term reward of the next state ok
and this is just a matrix form to write
the bellman equation V is a vector of
each of dimensional correspond to one
state and same for R and P is a
transition matrix here so just a
sixteenth way to write the bellman
equation
and as you can see the when you have a
lot of states that dimension of V is
huge so there's no way to scale up one
way to avoid this problem is that you
can use approximation
some people use new networks some people
use simpler things like a linear
approximation which is what we focus
here in linear function approximation we
approximate a value function by linear
combination of features where fee here
is the P dimensional feature and fader
is the parameter D dimensional parameter
we try to fit from data if you write it
in the matrix form like the one here you
can write it this way we have is a
vector of whose dimension is number of
states and fee is that the feature
matrix stayed by feature matrix and
theta is the a vector of P dimension
okay so so this is I think this is all
the notation most of the mutation and
then for impulsive evaluation what we
want to do is as follows what given a
set of data that is a trajectory of n
steps so we have this first day first we
wore in the next day next to avoid etc
until n steps later
unlike many supervised learning problems
for example requestion there's no target
label here right because we don't we
only observe intermediate the one step
rewards but what we try to estimate is
long term reward so usually what people
do in reinforcement learning is to use
other kinds of objective the most
popular one is probably means this guy
called mean square projector bellman
equation it's motivated by its inspired
by the the power equation so empowerment
equation if you remember here V is
called a fixed point solution to the
bellman equation because if you apply
the this up you can think of the
right-hand side as an operator right
given any function V we apply this
linear operator you get a new function
and in this case the V function happens
to be the fixed point of this equation
inspired by this you can think of
something like this you have let's say
you have a linear function approximation
a linearly approximated value function
you apply some apparent operator and
this guy in general does not lie in the
linear space of the feature that you
have right so you do a projection step
to project it back to the linear space
of just D dimensional feature you want
this projective value function to be the
same as the one you started with so this
is in a sense this is a different kind
of fixed point solution that you try to
solve for and so this is the just the
inspiration if you write write write
down the mathematical the mathematics
it's the function as this you want to
minimize this guy and this guy will put
in all the the notation that we show on
the previous slide it's a little bit
technical but it's straightforward to
write it down at the end of the day you
end up with something like this you have
a quadratic term here plus a possibly a
requisition term of the parameter and
this guy the matrix a and and vector B
and matrix C are computed here a it's a
average of individual the a is computed
on individual examples for individual
steps in each a sub T its a rank one
matrix and for P is a vector is also
averaged over all the steps similar for
C is a rank one matrix is similar to a
but if defined differently so that the
details of the a how a B and C are
defined here is are not important what
is important is that now we end up with
a objective function like this an A and
C are d dimensional a D by D matrix and
B is a the T dimensional matrix and this
is the objective function that we are
going to work on here so any question
about at this point
we have so you want to solve that
equation right right yeah you say that
it is precisely in theta star right yeah
so when you write a when you replace V
we have by this guy feature times of
parameter you put it here and you put in
all these distribution of sample and you
put in the transition probability well
essentially worker empirical projecting
mean square error replace this by the
empirical probabilities and you
eventually end up with this you talk
about the definition of projection it's
just the the standard l2 projection
depends on what do you mean by lose if
you it could be the case that after this
Pearman operator this is Lena spend okay
after the one-step operator the double
function can be way this far away from
the the space and out of reduction it
can change a lot so if you don't have
good features which is expected
this guy right so this is optional but
different kind I think you could use
people have used l1 I think that's
possible yeah I think it I think we can
change the del 1 decimal as long as
convex is fine and even if it's row is 0
which means that there's no
regularization of ours or everything
still works yeah which is something
interesting that I'll go back to at the
end of a top so this is the setup the
objective with this objective now I move
on to the the formulation of a set up is
the formulation of this objective as a
saddle point problem why do I need to do
that it's because of a challenge working
with mean square projection error so
this is just the the same objective that
I copied from the previous slide and A's
and B's and C's are decomposed like this
way of different from many supervised
learning problems like SVM or logistic
question for others this objective
function doesn't have the sum over data
structure okay in in classification
problems you have a circuit loss of the
cost equation error and sum over this
individual loss over all the data points
that you have in the training data and
then when you try to optimize these Sark
a loss you can sample the the data
points from the training set
stochastically and do stochastic we
discern right so this is and then you
can do all sort of things to speed that
up so this is very powerful but here
because the the structure of a B and C
here is not straightforward how you can
decompose that computation it on to
individual examples so this is the the
challenge here if you try to optimize
this objective function directly you can
oops you can end up with a squared
quadratic dependence on a number of
features and
recently about seven years ago and
Sutton in his colleagues including
Chavez over there has a nice algorithm
called GTD - that has linear dependence
of the number of features but then but
then the convergence rate is slow so
another question is whether we can still
get an algorithm that has a linear
convergence but linear complexity but
with much faster convergence speed and
it turns out that the starts with the
reformulation of the objective is a
saddle point problem so to do this let
me remind you of the conjugate function
given any function f of w you can define
a conjugate function of F star you this
way so this is the general but the
definition of the conjugate function if
your f is this quadratic function here
where the could wait it could wait it a
norm square function here then this two
function
it's of similar form except that now
that the weights from the weight just
the matrix D here becomes C inverse so
now we look at the mean square projected
by an error that we care about here it
has the sum of two parts this part is
like this right so what we can do is to
replace on this part of the right hand
side with something that looks more
complicated and then we end up with this
okay now this yellow part becomes this
bigger expression so it's instead of
having a minimization problem is before
now we have a minimax problem this
function let's call this objective
function has called L it takes us two
inputs failure and w failure is a primal
parameter we care about and W is a dual
parameter okay so the interesting thing
about this is that L is convex concave
is convex and theta and concave in W so
many minimax here is fine they were
minimizing a convex part in opt
maximizing a concave part so
it looks nice more importantly this
allows you to decompose decompose the
objective function into some of data
form so this is L and you can decompose
L into this because all the quantities
that we need to compute from data matrix
a vector B and matrix C they they are
averaged over the a sub T and B sub T
and C sub T won't be individual data
points right if you remember if you
write it down here so you so this is you
can this this part and this part as well
can be decomposed as a sum over all the
tape individual losses of data points so
and now so now for each one you can this
one can be easily computed from
individual data point once you realize
this connection then you can it's
straightforward to use existing
optimization to solve this set of point
problem for example you can use primer
to batch gradient descent it's very
straightforward as you can realize we
initialize the parameters both you
primal and dual and we iterates it
iteratively updates the the parameter
using gradient the gradients and sigma
theta and Sigma WS are the two step
sizes for theta and W and a great NP is
just the gradient of the partial
gradient of derivative with respect to
theta and with respect to W and you you
notice that there's a negative sign here
it's because here we want to max
minimize over theta but maximize over W
so there's less why there's a negative
sign here so that we can use - here but
other than that this is a very
straightforward algorithm based on the
gradient great descent and the iteration
cause you look at this it's linear in
the size of data points and the size of
the fish animation so it is nice and
later on I will show very brief
that this algorithm enjoys linear
convergence meaning that you Vantage
ensure that a solution is within epsilon
mistake or epsilon distance to the true
parameter you only need one of epsilon
iterations or steps to to get there but
still it's not very practical because it
has the linear dependence on em I mean
that every iteration you have to go over
the whole data set once can we do better
yes and you can think of stochastic
version of it the only difference is
that instead of computing the full
gradient now you randomly sample a data
points from one of these n data points
and compute a stochastic gradient and
then so L sub P is a loss for step T and
then the ATB t and city are in the or
the quantity for that step so now we
carry out the dependence on n because
the only depends on T now however
convergence is sub linear is slow
because here there is extra variance or
noise in the gradient the gradient is
not a true gradient of the objective
function you sample from it so it has
noise that slows out convergence and by
the way this turns out to recover the
GTT two algorithm which has been
observed two years ago by two papers so
now here comes the variance reduction
part in let's look at here the problem
that leads to the slow convergence here
is this guy that has high variance
compared to the gradient descent now
what we can do is to reduce the
variances of this guy how do we do it
there is a technical svrje stochastic
variance reduce gradient that does
exactly that what it does is to change
the replace the stochastic gradient by
this guy this guy has the D extra terms
in green you can think of that as some
kind of control very to reduce variance
first if for some data point some
subscript T it's far away from the true
gradient then these tends to cancel that
extra variance okay so that's that's how
we reduce variance of the whole thing or
if you look at it another way when you
run the algorithm for a long time this
theta bar W and a theta tilde and W
tilde they're close to your current
estimate and then these two terms are
almost the same so they almost cancel
each other and you end up with something
like this which is like a full gradient
algorithm but of course you need to
maintain this these extra copies of
parameters periodically hopefully the
hope is that on this update which
requires a pass of the over the food
data set this update does not happen too
often and in fact you can show that I
only happen very can happen only rarely
and and and the convergence right here
as the turnstile is linear because
because the variance reduction here and
then there's another technique called
saga that also reduces variance like s
vrg its idea is similar but the the
details are quite different one
difference is that it doesn't need a
periodic update of this batch Creegan
this guy here okay so you have one fewer
parameter to tune dense svr g which is
nice however it requires to maintain a
gradient for each in the day individual
data points which require extra space so
this is it makes it more challenging to
scale up but still one if you can afford
to do this it gives you a similar speed
up as svr g and then then we can extend
this to a policy policy evaluation where
you have a target policy to estimate but
your data points are generated by a
different policy does this is what we
call a policy learning it could be
useful when you collect one copy of data
and use that data to estimate multiple
policies you don't have to collect
several copies of data this can be
extended our solution can be extended to
a policy case the only difference is how
we define the ABC they're defined
similarly but using a different
distribution so so the algorithm and the
analysis that we're going to show are
applicable directly to this case and
similarly for for policy evaluation when
you have eligibility tracers the
durability traces is a trick in
reinforcement learning to to sort of
dude balances variance in a bias and
policy valuation it you can think of it
something to control the gap between
these two objective function which is
the project development equation and the
mean square of value function
approximation today I'm gone I'm not
going to do the details of these two but
but they're very similar to
to the standard policy evaluation case
okay
so these are the algorithms for variance
reduction and now what what are the
complicity bounds that we can get from
them here's a table that summarizes the
results for the first one l was TD is is
stands for least squares temporal
difference it confuses them it confused
the the the true parameter by using a
exact calculation made exact matrix
inversion to do a calculation and this
takes MD Square complexity to do it
exactly but it has the quadratic
dependence and the second one GTD too it
has linear dependence on the number of
features but unfortunately to get the
dependence on epsilon is selenium so
these are not the limitations and then
we put in in previous slides we talked
about the batch gradient and the
variance reduced gradients updates for
these two we have the the linear
convergence rate in this form meaning
that the error decays exponentially fast
more interestingly for strg and saga we
have we have this guy what is this guy
okay I should mention that in all this
all three bounds here the cover 1 cover
2 in kappa 3 these are algorithms
specific and constants ok and and if you
look at the analysis they they're about
a condition number that are used by this
algorithm so these three constants are
not comparable but what's interesting
thing here is that if you look at saga
and svr G if you have more and more data
no matter how big this constant is you
can you can reduce this condition number
by by 1 over n so a more and more data
then this SVR G and saga tends to be
faster than the batch gradient
Adonis analyzing the giving dis bounce
is it's not trivial so here I'm going to
use two slides only two slides to give
you a sense of the kind of analysis we
we do here is for this guy which is much
simpler than this from these analysis so
it's for you remember this is the batch
version that's gradient of the subtle
point problem okay these two numbers are
the step size and we define painter as
the ratio of the two step sizes and then
if you look at the update rule and and
let's data star in W star be the optimal
solution for the saddle point problem
and you look at the you apply the first
order of the married condition for this
guy and then combine this with the
update rule after some manipulation you
get a in an equation of this form where
Delta M roughly is speaking is the error
in the parameter how how far away it is
from the true parameter and and then the
after one more iteration the error is
changed to this guy and the change is
governed by this matrix I minus Sigma
the step size of theta times this matrix
3 so as you can imagine how fast this
guy the error vector decays to zero
depends on the eigen value of this
matrix right and then we have we have
found a previous result s as the
viewpager is large enough then this
matrix is diagonalizable so let's call
the the eigen decomposition to be Q
lambda Q inverse lambda is diagonal
matrix accuse the non singular matrix
the eigen vectors
now the continue we replace replace u
here by this eigen decomposition we get
this and we move the
Q's universe out and multiply both sides
by Q inverse to the left and we get
something like this so you can realize
that there's similarity here it if you
look at this term it this equation gives
you how this guy evolves after one more
iteration so this is exactly what we do
we capture how fast convergence happens
by this potential function the
protection function just two norm of
this guy and and because of this we have
this this inequality that tells you to
quantify how fast this potential
function may decay to zero and if you
can select the the step size properly
you can ensure that this happens
exponential well this potential function
two cases are exponentially fast and
because the parameter that we care about
we try to learn is upper bounded by the
norm of this Delta vector so in and this
Delta vector is in turn upper bounded by
two norm of the q square times the
potential function it sings the
potential function decay to zero
exponentially fast we have that the
parameter that we reach are optimized
also the case to the historic
exponentially fast
and then of course the most of the
analysis goes to analyzing the icon the
icon decomposition eigenvalues of the
matrix tree in other words we try to
analyze the q and lambda and but these
are more technical things and hopefully
we'll be able to put a paper on archive
soon and so you very interested feel
free to to take a look
but I hope this two slide gives you an
idea of how we approach the Getty the
convergence rate finally I'm going to
give you some very preliminary
experiments results on two very simple
problems you come competing algorithms
at this one is TD the standard the
standard positive evaluation the first
positive evaluation algorithm in linear
with linear functions and it has the sub
linear convergence rate and but the
update is cheap we also have the more
recent GTD this has similar performance
guarantees and then these two are the
two one that we propose here based on a
saddle point formulation and LCD is not
actually competing algorithm is a exact
solution so it serves as a reference
point and remember that is the expensive
compute the two problems very simple are
this one is random Mbps the other is
mounting car and this random VPS are
generated randomly by when be deciding
the transition probability and reward is
Thatcher and mountain car here is the
problem as we may know already is to try
to drive the car from some starting
point to to here to the star here and
this problem has two dimensions and
three actions you need to you either go
forward backward or remain neutral for
the car and the sample sizes are 100k
and 5k for the mining car and the
features are 200 and 300 respectively so
for random mdps
so here's the plot we have a number of
algorithms but Ravi's
speaking of a GED this the first two yep
let's look at the ID GDP - which is here
it's pretty slow because the condition
number of this problem is very bad it's
large so we think that if we add a
little bit more relative regularization
it will speed up LaMotte TD this guy
it's also slow and you think that it
doesn't you don't see a linear depend
convergence because here the objective
function is in the log this is the
objective function with in log scale so
and in contrast the the green one svrje
and this guy saga the two algorithm that
we propose they they enjoyed a roughly
linear convergence to the zero the
objective function similarly for
mounting cart where you have GT d now
it's slightly faster here and then TD is
this guy and this is the best one you
know it you may not be able to see but
after a long time the best one now
finally seem to be you have a linear
birth convergence as we predict in thief
theory and this this Guy'd SVR jury and
and in saga now after very quickly after
few more iterations the objective
function decays linearly here so to wrap
up this is motivated by a few related
work in the past most importantly are
the variants produced methods from
convex optimization including as via
Gianna saga by a few authors and more
recently there is a Francis box group
has a somewhere that applies various
production techniques to soft saddle
point problem but the approaches is not
directly applicable here because they
requires a proximal mapping in the
algorithm that are not efficiently
computed in impulsive valuation problem
here in here we are
operations or have linear dependent
linear complicity in dimension in
feature dimension furthermore the
algorithm requires that the objective
function is Jonny convex and strongly
concave in the primal and in a dual and
here we only require strongly concavity
in the dual but for the primer we don't
have to you remember that that means
that the role the parameter Rho can be
zero you know Chucky function which is
often the case and in practice when you
listen original our TD learning and then
and then early on there is the for in
post evaluation there is the gradient
based HEDIS like gt2 and GTI and GTD do
that we discuss in in this talk these
algorithms are derived from various
different principles they heavily rely
on the objective function and here we
take a different approach we reformulate
it as a saddle point problem and then we
can apply many techniques from the
literature optimization literature to
tackle this problem for a more
systematic and and principled approach
and I hope that this will I think this
is very powerful and interesting because
now it bridges the gap between
optimization and and in some problems in
reinforcement learning and we have shown
that in this talk that you can apply
variance reduction like SVG saga to
speed-up reinforcement learning now
can you now the question is how can we
perhaps there are other interesting
connection that you can have can borrow
from optimization to solve reinforcement
any problems feather ok oh sorry there's
also the incremental TD LST D it is
linear time but in it's an open question
to analyze this convergence rate is
unclear but empirically from the paper
it seems that the convergence is not
linear but it remains is an open
question ok so to conclude in this talk
we talk about a subtle point
reformulation of policy evaluation and
this allows us to build a connection
between reinforcement learning and an
optimization and
use techniques from optimization to
solve reinforcement learning better and
for future I think there are few
interesting things to look at one is to
extend the our linear case linear
function approximation case in only in a
case of course like in neural networks
which is quite popular these days but
it's very hard and the second one is to
extend it to control case we have looked
at possible vision when the policy is
fixed now can we can you apply similar
thing similar techniques to to learn the
optimal policy directly so that's the
what we mean by the control case here
it's also quite challenging but I think
it's worth looking at the theory is that
in general let's see let's see that
there's there may be a more interesting
gap well interesting connections between
optimization in RL and and it will be
interesting to to apply some of the
stuff in optimization community to to
better solve all your problems
okay I think that's the end of the talk
and yeah I'm happy to take questions
Thanks
[Applause]
and depends on I guess the structure of
it depends on a condition number of a
and B and yeah it's the expression is a
little bit complicated I don't remember
off the top of my head the condition
Debaters big enough oh the condition
it's all the condition numbers are a
condition number of empirical matrices
that you create so so when you get a
data you get a matrix and now you can
compute first of all you can compare all
the condition numbers of course it's
it's challenging it's hard but then at
least in principle you can compute them
and now you see what how big is big
enough it's worse than quadratic yes but
the point here is that as as in most
many optimization in practice you don't
those are ideal case and and then and
usually people tune the parameters a
little bit and in fact I think we have
results showing that when your learning
rate the step sizes are not as ideal as
we set in the theorem the performance
degrees nice gracefully meaning that
they still exponential but perhaps the
decay but the the explained x-men may be
lower
I think that well Simon did all of the
experiments and I think he tried a few
possibilities and and then which is
common in matter hyper parameter to name
some case I think you can choose a small
dataset here's some sample data then use
that small alias attitude a parameter to
find a reasonable range and then you
applied it one through your bigger ears
to what is the current but I think that
they are hoping that so here the
analysis assumes that you notice
previous yeah
hopefully the between if is not too far
away from those audio numbers and it's
fine and in fact the the the the the
most important quantity there is the
beta the ratio between the two
parameters so the parameters can be
small big but I think that the beta is
more important to control to control
that convergence
one of the main motivations for this
work is to be much much faster
computationally in terms of how many
iterations are needed in order to
converge so it seems like that should
particularly be helpful you are giving
such big improvements over TV which is
sort of effectively what that's a good
question I after this work I my
colleagues and I have been speculating a
few times and how to approach the
problem but our efforts failed so far so
perhaps it's not a good time with me to
speculate again but thing it's is quite
challenging it depends on a lot of
things suffering for example in the
nonlinear case even finding the fixed
point it's not completely obvious how to
define a fixed point solution or the how
to minimize the mean square the mean
square project abominate may have a
nonlinear shape so now you you find this
and then you perhaps you locally
linearize the space and projecting on
that but it's a little bit it's not I
think every certain has some paper in
past that depends on the smoothness
which are lies on the paper - yeah
so it's possible but it's challenging
debate there is a primal part of theta
in the dual part W the beta controls the
ratio of the learning rate right and and
then now that the problem is that the
two for the theta part of comission
number and the W parts condition number
they can be quite different so you need
beta to somehow to remove that to make
it more oscillations like
because you're going to have the LAN
main diagonals oh oh I see so you're
talking about condition phenomenon when
you try to do greatness on on build ill
condition problems right so you may
observe things like this yeah it's
possible yeah when you we don't have the
right beta to the center a step size
it's possible so you may have some
oscillation but but again the rate to
the question that it's it affects the
the condition number
so hopefully the the the dependence on
epsilon is still long one of epsilon but
before the dialogue term the constant
number which depend on condition number
is worse
[Applause]